bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport comme tous les lundis il est 18h30
si vous nous suivez en direct 51 à 14
c'est le score de la victoire écrasante
des Templiers ce weekend 4 ans après sa
dernière participation et l'encs
retrouver la Coupe d'Europe de foot US
et pour ce premier match de poule les
élan courtois recevaient le quintuple
champion du Royaume-Uni rien que ça les
blitz de Londres contre-rendu complet à
suivre évidemment en fin d'émission tous
les résultats du weekend mais on passe
tout d'abord au marathon
rum ils sont huit coureurs complètement
amateurs et ils viennent de réaliser un
rêve particip à leur premier marathon
lors du marathon justement de Rome le 23
mars dernier et ils ont tous franchi la
ligne aéolé de leur T-shirt de finisher
et de leur médaille certains une partie
de ces coureurs viennent nous raconter
cette expérience ce soir dans le 78
sport alors je vais faire un tour de
table en commençant par ma droite Céline
métro bonsoir à vous vous êtes
accompagné de votre camarade Alain
Richet bonsoir à gauche de la table
Christophe vitré et on va dire euh
l'entraîneur enfin en tout cas la
personne qui avait la casquette
d'entraîneur dans cette aventure Gérard
bourot bonsoir merci d'être là tous les
quatre dans le stat sport je sais aussi
que dans les coulisses il y en a encore
quelquesuns tout d'abord première
question on voit que bah vous avez tous
eu le t-shirt de finisher Céline c'est
déjà une belle satisfaction bah c'était
une grande une grande joie de pouvoir
tous arriver et franchir cette ligne
d'arrivée donc c'était vraiment un
accomplissement une satisfaction de
d'être arrivé au bout et ça on l'a fait
tous ensemble et justement quand vous
avez franchi la ligne al j' imagine que
c'est une grande fierté de se dire ça y
est j'ai fait mon premier marathon et
puis j'ai survécu ah oui c'est
l'aboutissement en fait de toute la
préparation parce qu'il y a eu plusieurs
semaines de préparation pour un marathon
et donc quand on voit la ligne d'arrivée
c'est non seulement les efforts des 42
km 195 qui viennent au bout mais en plus
toute une aventure humaine ce qui avait
toute une équipe Christophe quand on
fait son premier marathon comme celui de
Rome est-ce que c'est un marathon
difficile sur les chiqui on va dire un
peu mondial des marathon que l'on
connaît il y à Boston il à Paris comment
était-il ce marathon là euh difficile
d'avoir une mesure de comparaison parce
que c'était le premier mais dans
l'ensemble c'était un marathon qui était
quand même d'un niveau assez abordable
je pense pour l'ensemble de de l'équipe
enfin du groupe et et je dirais de des
coureurs en général il y avait assez peu
de dénivelés bon le quelques pavé par
moment mais rien de de bien méchant euh
et puis bah des surtout un beau parcours
dans la ville mythique de Rome donc
cétait c'était vraiment un marathon je
pense tout à
fait dans la norme pour en tout cas pour
nous pour démarrer alors je sais qu'on
vous Nimez pas quand on vous appelle
entraîneur Gérard mais vous aviez un
petit peu ce rôle là toute cette
préparation vous avez organisé le
planning les programmes de chacun un
petit peu individualisé sur une course
comme ça le jour J quel rôle aviez-vous
déjà je sais que vous courriez mais oui
donc je bien sûr accompagner mes mes mes
neuf camarades et surtout bah on a eu
quand même des conditions climatiques un
peu difficiles il faut le dire on a
quand même de la pluie de l'orage au
départ de l'orage aussi à la fin les
conditions de course étaaiit plutôt
sympa mis à part des pavés qui sont qui
sont un petit peu problématique au
niveau de de la tenue des foulets mais
sinon moi j'en doutais pas un instant je
l'avais même dit dans le lors que
lorsque vous aviez filmé lors de notre
entraînement j'ai jamais douté que tout
le monde finirait ça était plus
difficile pour certains des blessures
qui se sont réveillées bien sûr le
fameux mur pour certains au 30 35e km
mais on l' tous fini c'était le plus
important et justement est-ce que vous
avez dû accompagner certains qui étaient
peut-être en difficulté pendant ces 42
km 195 ou pas oui oui on a eu bien bien
sûr une de nos
concurrentes qui a eu un petit problème
au niveau d'une tendinite qui s'est
réveillé au niveau du genou donc
quelques difficultés pour terminer mais
elle avait le moral elle avait le je
crois que c'est surtout ça qu' l' qu'
l'a tenu et on on l'a terminé ensemble
oui alors vous l'avez tous terminé je le
disais et puis il y a eu des bons temps
quand même des bonnes surprises sur
cette première édition notamment vous
Céline pour votre premier marathon 4h6
c'est plutôt plutôt vrai que ça fait
plus de 10 kmh de moyenne c'est une
belle performance ouais je suis contente
de ce temps c'est vrai que je visais
secrètement 4h mais avec le recul je me
dis que ouais c'est un temps c'est un
bon temps et je suis contente donc ça me
donnera une motivation pour le pour le
prochain marathon de d'atteindre les
4hures à côté de vous il y avait pas un
petit peu de vent il y avait il y avait
Christophe à 4h3 et puis et puis Alain
je regarde dans mes fiches 4h51 donc
c'est quand même aussi des temps plus
plutôt correct je me réfère un petit peu
au spécialistes en dessous de 5 he sur
un premier marathon en général c'est une
satisfaction non oui je je dirais puis
surtout quand même les conditions
climatiques je le répète était quand
même un peu un peu difficile donc c'est
clair que ou entre je dira entre 4h30 et
5h pour un premier marathon c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt une très belle performance
on sait pas trop où on va et c'est vrai
que on essaie de gérer et je trouve que
que tout le monde a plutôt bien géré la
course donc vous étiez donc un htiv
Linois je le rappelle sur ce marathon de
r vous en parliez tout à l'heure Gérard
ce fameux mur des 30 km Alain comment
vous vous l'avez appréhendé alors c'est
vrai que moi je l'ai eu justement un
petit peu avant les 30 km euh et en fait
c'est surtout une perte de motivation
c'est-à-dire qu'on a plus envie de de
courir et là c'est très difficile faut
vraiment puiser dans ses réserves pour
se dire je vais aller au bout de ce
marathon et c'est vrai que ça demande
quand même une motivation importante B
que l'on avait parce que on a tout le
groupe nos amis aussi qui courent avec
nous et la préparation c'est vrai qui
nous a permis d'aller au bout ça veut
dire qu'à ce moment momentl le physique
tenait encore la route si j'ose dire
c'était vraiment un aspect un problème
mental oui alors c'est vrai que de mon
côté en tout cas moi je suis parti
plutôt doucement parce que je ne
connaissais pas cette distance des 40
km et effectivement ça m'a permis
peut-être d'avoir moins de douleur que
d'autres donc effectivement au 30e km
j'avais pas de problème physique c'était
plutôt l'envie d'aller au bout pour les
autres pour Christophe est-ce qu'il y a
eu des des moments de souffrance on en
parle un petit peu c'est vrai que c'est
toujours difficile à gérer 42 km ça peut
paraître très très long j'ai j'ai très
bien vécu on va dire les 35 premiers 35
30 entre 35 38 bon je senti un peu de
baisse de tenus mais je m'inquiétais pas
je dis c'est normal c'est c'est c'est la
la distance qui commence à faire son son
effet plus le temps et entre 39 et 42 là
je me suis accroché en me disant il y en
a derrière ils sont toujours pas arrivés
ils sont loin derrière et ça ça été le
truc qui m'a qui m'a tenu jusqu'au bout
en me disant je lâche rien je vais
jusqu'au bout euh je sais qu'il y en a
dans le groupe qui sont qui ont qui ont
mal au genou qui ont mal au pied ou
ailleurs donc je continue parce que moi
finalement j' une légère douleur dessus
du pied mais je dirais que c'était quand
même tout à fait gérable j'ai dis bon
allez je lâche pas j'y vais au mental et
vraiment ou parce qu'après c'est juste
on réfléchit plus à son état physique on
on on court juste par habitude
quon ça devient mécanique il y a plus de
réflexion et comme vous avez dit Gérard
Moné vous aurez cette difficulté et il
faut vous fixer sur une idée positive
quelque chose qui vous permett de tenir
c'est ce que j'ai fait et c'est comme ça
que voilà je suis arrivé jusqu'au bout
en en continuant je dirais la la course
sans marché quoi pour pour finir deux
petites questions encore quelle image
vous allez garder de ce premier marathon
on va commencer par Alain ah B
effectivement c'est le finish le fait de
franchir cette ligne d'arrivée euh et
puis sur c'est vrai une ville assez
mytique Rome où euh on a traversé quand
même donc l'arrivée c'est proche du
Colisée on passe par le Vatican euh donc
c'est vraiment des monuments
extraordinaire et un un très très beau
souvenir partagé avec tout le monde qui
est à l'arrivée Céline de votre côté
l'image rapidement c'est le départ aussi
on était tous on s'est tous motivés pour
pour franchir cette ligne de départ et
c'est vrai que c'est un moment assez
mouvant parce que ça y est on y était la
l'aboutissement en fait de toutes ces
tout cette préparation le concret je
passe le relais à Christophe moi c'est
un ensemble c'est un niveau émotionnel
qui est monté en crchendo et une belle
aventure à la fois personnelle et
collective avec des amis ce qui était
formidable dernière question on peut pas
y couper j'imagine qu'un premier
marathon ça donne envie de repartir pour
pour d'autres épreuves non forcémentou
ou on est dans l'analyse des des
prochains marathons regarde pour Madrid
éventuellement donc avec le même coach
avec j'espère que j'espère que mon
contrat sera recuit reconduit un coach
bévool et passionné merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre et merci à tous pour
l'accueil que vous nous avez réservé
pant vre préparation on suivra ça de
près si toutefois il y a un prochain
marathon à très bientôt
merci 4 ans après leur dernière
participation j'en parlais dans les
titres les Templiers deslancour
retrouvit la coupe cou d'Europe de foot
US pour ce premier match de Pol il
recevait le quintuple champion du
Royaume-Uni les blitz de Londres image
d'éodim moine en collaboration avec les
équipes de
templiété il l'avait annoncé en début de
saison les Templiers veulent tout gagner
cette année et un titre européen passé
par une victoire face au blitz de
Londres compact et lencour débloque
rapidement le compteur 3-0 après ce coup
de pied de Cyril
gérrard pass et voilà premier point mais
la défense se fait surprendre quelques
minutes plus tard sur cette passe de Joe
Thompson pour Charlie Joseph attention
ben
Thomson le premier touch magnifique et
là il y a un gros problème d'assignation
voilà cterb est resté très calme dans sa
poche il a vu que ça arrivait mais il a
attendu si les Templiers réagissent par
Jérémy laroc et mène 10 à 7 dans ce
premier Act il semble paralysé par
l'enjeu en face le jeu londonien est
varié et bien en place rien ne semble le
pouvoir enrier la machine orchestrée par
Joe Thomson et alors qu'il reste 5
secondes de jeu dans cette première
période les Blitz frappe à nouveau
attention Thomson qui va ça donne toute
façon il va jouer la but sur le 10 oh
belle défense
oh
touchdou il a réussi à la récupérer
super touchdown mag on pouvait s'y
attendre qu'il allait jouer sur le 10
l'homme a tout faire de cette équipe
Jack dy permet au londonien de mener 14
à 10 à la pause on s'est mis ni-même
dedans on a fait des fautes en attaque
au début on a essayé de la commencer
doucement lentement et de monter mais
c'est pas le jeu qu'il fallait donc on
tout de suite installer notre force on a
sorti nos receveurs qui vraiment la
forceli au retour des vestiaires les
joueurs d'manuel char semble transformer
et ses receveurs supersonic vont sortir
du bois à commencé par Anthony Couvin
sur cette passe courte de SH Shelton
l'international français va flirter avec
la touche sur 40 Yard les défenseurs
londonnien
VO il est passé il a accéléré terminé et
voilà ça c'est
anon les Templiers repassent devant 17 à
14 au Royaume-Uni le championnat élite
n'a pas encore débuté et cela se voit au
fil des minutes physiquement le Blitz
sombre les Londoniens laissent des
boulevards au receveur et l' en courtois
il n'en fallait pas plus pour la
mobylette Anthony Couvin Showtime va
justifier son surnom à trois reprises
il TER BL et per au temp de restc àile
deoule européenne et pour finir le
travail son compère jé laroc
réceptionnera une dernière passe deelton
cétait l'objetif j'avais c'est non
seulement la victoire mais surtout une
victoire large dans cette formule il y a
des adversaires qu'on rencontre pas ça
va jerage il faut absolument qu'on gagne
match fin
5 le quintup le champion du Royaume-Uni
et surtout envoie un message clair à
toute l'Europe du foot
US allez on passe aux autres résultats
du
weekend pour le compte de la 14e journée
de Division d'Honneur Versailles 8e
recevait au stade montburon ce weekend
le pariss-germain l'équipe 3 je vous
rassure si les joueurs de David jiger
réalise une belle première période en
inscrivant de buts après la pause les
Versaillais reculent et doivent faire
face à la pression parisienne Paris qui
reviendra au score sur ce débordement
côté gauche la défense versaillaise ne
parvennant pas à se dégager Versailles
s'impose finalement de buts à 1 et
retrouve la victoire près de 2 mois
après son dernier succès aux Ulis un
succès qui fait du bien aux ivelinois
désormais 5e au classement il y avait
pas de psychose au sein du groupe
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
matchs où notamment en Melin il y a 15
jours on se fait rattraper à 30 secondes
de la fin sur un penalty bon maintenant
effectivement l'objectif c'est de gagner
des points pour pour finir une fin de
saison un peu plus confortable c'est
fait voilà on va pouvoir aborder les 5in
derniers matchs tranquillement en rugby
plaisir a conclu la saison comme il
l'avait débuté par une victoire le persc
s'est imposé sur la pelouse de sucici ce
dimanche 33 à 19 et term 2e de sa poule
les joueurs de Philippe Béard attendent
de connaître leur adversaire en 32e de
finale en football féminin 18e journée
de Division 2 et c'est toujours la même
histoire pour Montini les in montaines
se sont inclinés à domicile face au Val
d'Orge 4 buts à 2 et avec cette 16e
défaite de la saison la plus mauvaise
défense du championnat reste lanterne
rouge ave avec 24 petits points et
surtout à 12 points du premier non
relégable Dijon à 4 journées de la fin
du championnat la messe est dite pour
Montini une info de golf pour continuer
Victor dubisson et grè do seront
présents au Golf National à 50 ans en
Eveline pour la 98e édition de l'Alstom
Open de France du Buisson actuel 23e
joueur mondial sera le leader du clan
tricolore de cette édition il
participera là à son open national pour
la 6e fois de sa carrière tournoi auquel
il a participé pour la première fois à
l'âge de 15 ans devenant ainsi le plus
jeune golfeur de l'histoire à prendre
part à un tournoi de l'Européan tour il
retrouvera donc au Golf National grem
McDowell le champion en titre qui pointe
à 34 ans au 14 r mondial les deux
joueurs seront les premiers sont les
premières tête d'affiche à confirmer
leur participation au plus ancien open
national d'Europe continental vous
pourrez les admirer sur les grines de
l'Albatros du 3 au 6 juillet prochain du
tennis de table pour continuer et
mauvaise nouvelle pour les féminines de
l'Entente voisin saint-arnou promu en
National 1 en décembre dernier les
joueuses de geoffré Nisan ont dû
déclarer forfait pour le reste de la
saison suite à la blessure du de la
petite jeune espoir veren Frid Vinson
l'entraîneur vcinois n'avait plus de
joueus à disposition pouvant évoluer à
ce niveau et aucune entente n'a été
trouvée avec la Fédération résultat
forfait général et relégation
automatique en National 2 pour la saison
prochaine depuis janvier pour rappel les
linoises n'avaient gagné aucun match en
N1 une info de tennis fauteuil et des
nouvelles de notre champion de tennis
fauteuil iblinois Johan Kyou qui s'est
illustré sur le circuit mondial ces
dernières semaines et notamment sud
américain Laurent bolitin s'est imposé
sur l'OP d'Argentine et l'op du Chili
cette fois-ci en simple et en double
grâce à ses succès Yan kiu se isse
désormais à la 26e place mondiale
l'objectif des Rio 2016 est donc bien
parti une dernière info duball Stéphane
paysan l'ancien entraîneur de montigé et
désormais le nouveau coach de Versailles
après avoir arrêté sa collaboration
historique avec la S Montin bal à
l'automne dernier l'entraîneur yvelinois
a trouvé un nouveau challenge dans le
département et vient de signer avec le
club versaillais il prendra ses
fonctions dans les prochaines semaine
c'est la fin de ce 78 sport merci encore
une fois de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine lundi cette fois à
18h30 excellente soirée sur
TVfil